[Musique]
aujourd'hui jeudi 9 juillet 2015 bonsoir
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres
le ministre de la défense jean yves le
drian en déplacement à saint germain en
laye ce matin un déplacement auprès des
soldats engagés dans l'opération
sentinelle visant à renforcer la
sécurité en france plusieurs mesures
pour améliorer leurs conditions de vie
annoncée c'est depuis versailles que se
prépare le traditionnel défilé militaire
du 14-juillet reportage auprès des
soldats en pleine préparation
le financement participatif qui est
contre un peu d'argent permet d'obtenir
quelques avantages de la part d'un
porteurs de projets se développent et
nous verrons comment se prépare
actuellement depuis les yvelines une web
série l'a baptisé f 44,81 ces
réalisateurs invités du journal le
ministre de la défense jean yves le
drian était donc à saint germain en laye
aujourd'hui il a visité à cette occasion
la base militaire du camp des loges dans
le cadre de l' opération sentinel
une action qui vise à protéger les
populations contre les actes terroristes
sur notre territoire français sur place
michael et demi d'euros accompagné de
william l visite ministérielle ce matin
au camp des loges de
saint-germain-en-laye jean yves le drian
ministre de la défense a rencontré ce
jeudi l'état major et les militaires de
la base
l'homme politique a annoncé à cette
occasion une série de mesures pour
améliorer le quotidien des soldats
mobilisés pour l'opération sentinelles
une action lancée après les attentats de
janvier pour protéger la france contre
le terrorisme le ministre a annoncé une
revalorisation salariale de 150 euros
par mois pour les hommes et des
bungalows climatisés il faut faire en
sorte que nos soldats qui se relaient en
particulier dans la région parisienne il
ya quatre mille soldats en permanence
puisse avoir des conditions de vie de
travail qui soit plus confortable que
celle qu'ils ont pu avoir au départ
pendant leur quartier libre les soldats
mobilisés devrait également avoir un
accès privilégié à des loisirs avec des
places de cinéma de spectacles ou des
matches de football
ils font des périodes difficiles des
journées difficiles et puis reste là
quatre cinq six semaines et parfois
plusieurs fois dans l'année et donc
il mérite la reconnaissance de la nation
c'est indispensable au camp des loges
ces mesures ont été forcément accueilli
avec des sourires par les soldats la
plupart des militaires missionné pour
l'opération dormait depuis plusieurs
mois dans les conditions précaires après
des journées de plus de 17 heures c'est
un moment important parce que c'est un
c'est l'expression de la considération
et de reconnaissance de la nation du
ministère pour cette mission qui est
difficile qui est compliqué qui est
fatigante et donc voilà ces mesures sont
vraiment bien accueilli on peut estimer
que l'on peut rester dans des conditions
de vie très précaires pendant trois
semaines
ni pendant trois mois ni pendant trois
ans et donc c'est toutes ces mesures qui
ont fait l'objet de gros travaux pour
prendre pendant ces six mois et qui
aujourd'hui trouve le moment de la
décision
l'opération sentinelle est prolongée
jusqu'à une date indéterminée
actuellement plus de 7000 soldats sont
mobilisés pour lutter contre le
terrorisme dans toute la france le coût
de l'opération s'élève à environ un
million d'euros par jour
3500 militaires vont défiler le 14
juillet sur les champs-elysées pour la
première fois les unités de l'opération
sentinelle justement ils vont intégrer
les rangs elle est répétée sur les
répétitions ont commencé ce matin
garde à vous les répétitions du défilé
du 14 juillet ont commencé ce matin je
vous demande la plus grande
concentration niveau personnel et bien
sûr de l'application dans les gestes
habituels de l'ordre serré au coeur du
défilé les forces françaises engagées
sur le territoire national et sur les
théâtres d'opération depuis les
attentats du mois de janvier
l'opération sentinelle sera représenté
notamment par le raid et le gign ou
encore ces militaires qui surveille
sites sensibles et lieux publics
l'armée de l'air la marine et l'armée de
terre sont réunis
la plupart défileront pour la première
fois qu'il faut laver la tête
regardez d'autorité dans les yeux et à
trois pierres le défilé défilé sur les
champs-elysées c'est un honneur pour
n'importe quel militaire ce soit de
l'armée de terre ou de l'armée de l'air
de la marine s'est représenté donc à la
fois son régiment et son armée devant le
président de la république
c'est un honneur pour tout militaire
c'est un honneur quand même une fois
dans sa carrière de défiler sur les
champs-elysées allez fais partie du
la mission sentinelle informatif de dès
le mois de janvier dès que ça pue l'acte
là on est parti le sens même faut
attendre plus ce vote ressemble plus mal
sans doute vers l'avant bravo des gestes
millimétrés un alignement presque
parfait les troupes et répètent sous le
regard attentif du général bazin qui
scrutent le moindre faux pas invitée
d'honneur cette année le défilé
accueillera dans ses rangs le mexique
les répétitions s'enchaînent au bio
jusqu'à la semaine prochaine pour
arriver à la perfection le 14 juillet
sur les champs-elysées f40 4.81
peut-être la nouvelle web série est donc
vous ne pourrez plus vous passer ses
créateurs sont en tout cas en train de
monter le projet via notamment un
financement participatif sur internet
ils vont tous nous expliquer dans un
instant voici déjà le générique de cette
web série pour se mettre dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
thomas le rudulier co réalisateurs
scénaristes bonsoir ce bar nous dit
bonsoir c'est une co réalisateur donc
monteur et acteur yvelinois à l'origine
de cette web série en cours de
développement f40 4.81 on vient de
découvrir un peu l'atmosphère avec ce
secours générique qui se lance pour
présenter le sujet alors donc c'est une
web série qui traite d'un sujet plutôt
sérieux qui est là le thème des
personnalités multiples donc le
personnage souffre de cette maladie
plusieurs personnalités de l'habiter il
va résoudre des enquêtes en utilisant
les capacités de ces différentes
personnalités
le trouble de la personnalité multiple
troubles qui a 10 aussi l identité ça
existe c'est un regret cas médical vous
avez travaillé comme d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet alors par des recherches
bibliographiques
il ya un très bon livre donc les mille
et une vies de billy milligan qui
traitent de sujets sur un patient qui
était atteint 2,5 et v 22 personnalités
je crois psychose shutter island rail
club
tout ça c'est des thèmes des sujets qui
sont abordés à travers ces films là ça
vous a inspiré
vous voulez vous en d'écarter quelques
est ce qui fera la différence avec votre
web série on s'en inspirer en s'en
écarte c'est
on prend comment dire c'est un peu le
bagage de chacun en fait il n'ya pas de
d'héritage direct mais plus le bagage de
tout un chacun qui passe aussi bien par
la littérature la peinture que dans les
films aussi vous êtes acteur également
que vous allez jouer dans cette note
c'est getafe
comment vous vous avez travaillé on va
préparer à tout ça parce que je vais
avoir bas c'est à dire qu'on prend
chaque personnage à part et on les
travaille comme pour un rôle à part
donc là il y en a trois donc c'est trois
fois plus de travail mais c'est trois
fois plus de plaisir aussi
est-ce que vous avez déjà travaillé
ensemble il me semble un sur des courts
métrages et autres est un petit peu
votre bagage cette fois ci en terme
d'expérience ont fait des bonds s'est
amusé affirmé lundi court métrage pour
pour s'entraîner pour s'amuser un petit
peu la patte
mais là on passe au niveau au dessus
c'est à dire que tout ce qu'ils avaient
avant ben on l'oubli et là c'est le
blockbuster de notre association est
commissionné 2b est ainsi très sain est
d'ailleurs pour avoir tous à tous les
détails développement en cours ce sera
une websérie sur quel format plusieurs
saisons plusieurs épisodes c'est déjà
défini alors pour la première saison
donc il y aura cinq épisodes et il y
aura donc plusieurs saisons le nombre
n'est pas encore fixée on sait où on va
mais on se laisse la possibilité de
développer plus en saison
tout est déjà écrit tout n'est pas écrit
la fin est écrite la première saison est
écrite et puis il reste comment y
arriver ça dépendra quand il s'est reçu
ensuite accueilli par le public alors
pour financer tout ça il faut du
financement un petit peu même si c'est
fait en partie sur du bénévolat ça s'est
fait notamment via internet avec une
plateforme de financement c'est
d'ailleurs de plus en plus fréquent pour
développer des projets c'est notre
question du jour avez vous ai déjà
participé à ces plateformes de
financement participatif pense que ça
peut être sympa après faut voir au
niveau des dérèglements comolli
s'arrangent entre eux ça mais il ya des
gens qui ont beaucoup d'argent et tu
peux vraiment prêter à d'autres pour
créer des choses donc votre qui le prête
à s'en soucier s'en servent pas j'ai
déjà fait mais c'était pour une
association étudiante pour partir en
voyage humanitaire pour financer les
billets d'avion
toute l'organisation je trouve ça bien
quand il y en a vraiment besoin
c'est dire pour les petites entreprises
qui peuvent marcher mais qui n'ont pas
forcément les fonds je trouve ça bien
malin pour d'autres personnes qui en
rajoute et qui se servent d'autres
causes pour ça pour cv dans la poche non
pas forcément
non j'en ai jamais fait mais je m'y
intéresse puisqu'on est dans un master
de communication digitale donc c'est
qu'on trouve ça assez génial voici
l'économie calédonienne l'économie de
demain l'économie et du partage avec le
prime de crise en grèce il ya justement
un monsieur qui est à lancer un
financement pour essayer de combler la
dette de la grèce et je trouve ça
vraiment pas mal je pense que c'est les
nouveaux moyens de financement de demain
et c'est assez toc là c'est pas pour
financer la dette de la grèce un exemple
de financement participatif dont nous
parlerons ce soir c'est cette web série
f 44 points 81
vous avez utilisé la plateforme ulule
pour financer un petit peu il ya bien un
seuil de 2500 euros jusqu'au 5 juillet
que vous n'avez pas atteint 70% se sont
taillé pour cent c'est jamal somme c'est
quand même une belle somme on a bien
travaillé
un petit regret quand même ne pas
valider la cagnotte mais on est passé
sur un autre système de cagnotte
justement sans limite recycler sur
litchi et les gens peuvent continuer à
la donnons vous aider à quoi va servir
cet argent et pourquoi utiliser ce
système là d'ailleurs juste pour la
location de matériel parce que ça très
très vite et c'est très très cher pour
dédommager pour les sens pour tout ce
qui est nourriture parce que bien
entendu il faut bien manger sur un
tournage
toutes ces petites choses qui mises bout
à bout
arrivé à une certaine somme et si on la
sort de notre poche est évidemment un
peu difficile mais combien de personnes
sur ce projet on est pour l'instant
7 8 8 pour le pilote mais après ça va ça
qu'on dit qu'ils ont décidé de s'engager
aussi sur une part de bénévolat mais
vous voulez un résultat professionnel
malgré tout quel est le profil un petit
peu des gens qui vont participer on a
entendu la musique aussi tout à l'heure
avec avec le générique
il ya un vrai travail sur la musique on
a un compositeur qui nous a rejoint le
projet lui a plu et il a eu envie de
composer grenoblois et camille en images
napoléon et non un spectacle sur
napoléon qui passe certainement ces
temps ci à grenoble les gens qui vous
accompagnent un certain bagage ou par
les blockbusters tout à l'heure pour
votre association c'est véritablement le
but de ce projet est utilisé pour
revenir sur ce sujet de ces plateformes
de financement participatif ce genre de
système là aussi ça permet d'être plus
libres ou en tout cas de faire ses
preuves
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé vers ce
système permet déjà de on a une liberté
d'expression qui est beaucoup plus
grande puisque on peut avoir des stands
on sortir des standards vraiment et
c'est une manière aussi d'impliquer les
gens donc dans le projet est votre
ambition c'est quoi c'est de rester sur
ce forme de système là où ensuite de
professionnaliser tout ça pourquoi pas
de le développer avec un studio après on
s'en veut aussi prouver si on peut
effectivement approché un studio une
faute à une production
une fois que cela a été mis en route
quitte à refaire ce qu'on sait jamais
mais pense pouvoir accrocher une
production
donc c'est aussi pour faire ses preuves
que vous tout à fait plus que moi c'est
une sorte de l'ombre de lancement cette
web série alors donc vous n'avez pas
atteint cette somme de 2000 2500 euros
nécessaires sur la plateforme l'ul
malgré tout il ya toujours cette
cagnotte dont les renseignements sur
votre site internet pour pouvoir
continuer à vous aider à développer tout
ça et vous allez commencer le tournage
bientôt voilà cet été le tournage
commencera ce sera quoi où quand
précisément si on vous croit plusieurs
sites donc sur saint cyr sur versailles
aussi et puis un petit bout en essonne
pour tourner à tous est comme ça dit la
fin déjà écrite s'est sauvé dévoiler un
peu la teneur du pilote
le pilote plutôt sombre pose pas mal de
questions aussi donc on veut faire
réfléchir les gens tout à fait ce qu'on
veut c'est que les spectateurs soient un
peu spectacteurs en quelque sorte au
soir le but n'est pas de faire de
forcément du grand spectacle mais qui
est aussi la réflexion à rester sur ce
talent-là médical flexibles et ça à
savoir aussi que le premier épisode
n'est pas le premier que tout commence
dans le deuxième d'accord très bien donc
il faut qu'ils mènent dès le début
faudra bientôt suivre y tenons à nous en
parler dès que ce sera la tournée on
pourra en diffuser à quelles quelques
extraits avec maintien à tous les deux
d'être venu le site internet n'oubliez
pas pour en savoir plus sur ce projet f
44 points avec 80 merci à tous les deux
vous pourriez vous nous allons parler de
septième art encore dans quelques
instants avec le maire adjoint en charge
de la culture à bois d'arcy puisque le
cinéma de la commune sera ouvert durant
le mois de juillet ça c'est une première
mais tout d'abord un portrait pour
poursuivre cette édition on les côtoie
parfois quotidiennement mais que sait-on
précisément de leur activité ce sont les
gardiens et les gardienne d'immeuble
rencontre avec l'une d'entre elles elle
officie depuis dix ans à guyancourt
c'est un portrait signé catherine je
l'attends comme tous les matins
christine d eau lac seront dans ce local
de service elle prépare son matériel
le matin cette opération nettoyage des
eaux les cages d'escalier les vitrines
et les poussières
voilà j'ai eu 9 points comme ça à faire
elle s'occupe aussi de sortir les
poubelles de les replacer dans les
locaux et parfois c'est la mauvaise
surprise et vite
c'est un local encombrant mais j'ai des
jeunes qui squattent donc ils passent
par au dessus il arrive à mourir la
porte donc voilà mais bon le week end je
le vois pas mais je sais qui c'est à la
fois ils ont tout nettoyé parce que j'ai
bien vu les saletés qui m'ont fait donc
j'ai posé des ballets et mon tout
nettoyer et c'est rentré dans l'ordre
sauf qu'il ya c'est souvent le répéter
sinon ça va mais là la preuve c'est
reparti racault n'est reparti pour un
tour
les signes de ce lac est gardienne
d'immeuble dans cette résidence sociale
de guyancourt depuis dix ans ici elle
gère 76 logements sa journée démarre à 8
heures et termine à 17h27 précisément
elle n'est pas logé sur place des
gardiens qui sont logés et eux ils
travaillent jusqu'à 18h comme enjeu sera
logé donc je suis jusqu'à 17h 2007
l'après midi est consacré à la partie
administrative c'est pour le loyer
oui nico disait c'est possible la gd
certain qu'ils payent encore hanche est
qu'ils ne veulent pas être prélevés donc
bien où ça qu'on fait des encaissements
en arrivant au cices je fais les
relances sur les 76 locataires christine
enregistre 6 impayées par mois en
moyenne
la gardienne d'immeuble s'occupe aussi
des contrats de location est du volet
sécurité pour vérifier que les travaux
d'entretien sont bien effectués
christine est régulièrement en contact
des locataires le contact est souvent
aisés avec ses locataires qu'elle
connaît bien comme ce monsieur qui
habite ici depuis 20 ans qualité d'âme
au gardien c'est la présence pense car
certains locataires sont devenus de plus
en plus exigeants ils demandent de plus
en plus donc
et comme nous on n'a pas le monopole de
tous nos gardiens dont qu'il pense des
fois que c'est nous qui bloqueront et
qu'on bloque pas comment il ya des
procédures à suivre le maître mot être
le plus réactif possible c'est surtout
les demandes techniques
quand il ya des problèmes de plomberie
de chaudières de radiateur
infiltration façades toitures tous ces
choses là c'est ils sont très demandeurs
vous êtes réactif c'est surtout ça est
assez réactivité que ça dure pas trop
longtemps les attentes d'entreprise
après il faut gérer les entreprises donc
ça c'est encore autre chose
christine est gardienne depuis 22 ans
après qu'elle et son mari ont quitté les
ardennes
son mari était mineure aux charbonnages
de france et elle couturières qu'on a
formé une formation de six semaines avec
logirep sur plus tôt donc voila et après
on a été embauchée sur clamart pendant
12 ans et après chercher ici depuis 10
ans sur guyancourt village le
gardiennage a beaucoup évolué à l'époque
quand on a démarré on travaille sur le
petit minitel on faisait nos
encaissements nous gérons loyer voilà
mais tout le reste ans se faisait
administrer par la main aujourd'hui tout
administratifs ont créé beaucoup de
formations et je trouve ça génial parce
que nous irons on apprend on apprend et
en apprendre
christine désole axe occupent des
logements de guyancourt elle a aussi en
charge de l'administration dans deux
autres résidences
elle prendra ses vacances au mois d'août
à l'évasion
à les inviter à présent pour conclure
cette édition jean philippe plus bonsoir
mon sens est maire-adjoint en charge de
la culture et de la modernisation des
services publics et du développement
économique sur la commune de narcy en
plateau ce soir parce que il ya du
nouveau du côté du cinéma du nouveau
dans votre commune la grange de la
tramblais sera ouverte durant tout le
mois de juillet ça c'est une première
pourquoi ce choix déjà bas c'est une
c'est une première c'est une nouveauté
en effet on a voulu en fait revoir la
politique cinématographique sur le
climat de relative sur la ville
auparavant on avait un festival mort des
toiles qui étaient au moins 2 au mois de
juillet et la problématique qu'on a eu
c'est faire une politique à peu plus
abordable grand public plutôt
qu'élitiste qui était auparavant
donc là notre volonté c'est donc de tout
au mois du tout au long du mois de
juillet ouvrir ce cinéma et notamment le
samedi soir il ya un petit événement
puisque en fait on offre un cocktail
pour je me place achetée et les
diffusions de films assez sympathique
donc ce serait me disait tu seras
jurassique world et en complément au
mois d'août on participe à l'office au
ciment pm menée par conseil
départemental avec un film qui sera
diffusé le 29 août en plein air sur la
place de trop mais aussi en fait cette
décision de d'ouverture ce cinéma et en
faisant une programmation grand public 1
vous avez mentionné jurassique world il
y aura aussi à découvrir les films
récents vice versa les profs de aussi
côté français par exemple dit familial
c'est une refonte complète de votre
politique familiale culturelle en fait
politique culturelle de la commune c'est
absolument une refonte de la petite
culturel on veut la rendre beaucoup plus
abordable et accessible à l'ensemble des
arcisien donc à cette ouverture du
cinéma l'été on va on va retrouver à
partir de la rentrée un dessiné mardi
des mois d'octobre donc tous les mardis
soirs des diffusions ces métaux
graphique avec des échanges sont nés
avec des réalisateurs ou sur des
thématiques spécifiques et un festival
de début novembre qui sera un festival
innovant un peu original première fois
qu'on le fera sur la ville donc je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion de reparler à la
rentrée et puis tout au long de l'année
aussi une politique cinématographique
qui est déclinée pour les événements
alors que ce soit 11 novembre le 8 mai
absolument
les projections exactement à la fête de
la nature aussi mené par le cmj on a
diffusé on a diffusé un film de yann
arthus bertrand avec des liens très
forts forcément avec les archives
françaises du film parce qu'elles sont
installés à bois d'arcy hier un
partenariat qui se met en place avec les
documentalistes
absolument il ya un partenariat qui est
mis en place qui était déjà mis en place
mais qu'on va accentuer dans le cas
notamment des mardis du cinéma pour les
faire intervenir et travailler avec eux
ça vous l'avez mentionné mardi de cinéma
à partir du mois d'octobre et puis le
festival international de films très
courts a été lancée cette année 6 juin
dernier c'était la deuxième édition
ça a plutôt bien marché une 150
participants donc on va capitaliser
dessus et relancer sa la saison
prochaine les choses un peu innovante
serait qu'on le faisait pas forcément
encore sur la commune auparavant mais on
va beaucoup communiqué avec lançant une
page facebook et un twitter sur le sur
le fond mais a tremblé pour ceux qui n'y
ont pas encore participé ce festival du
film très court il fonctionne comment
c'est tout simplement en fait la
diffusion de deux fûts de films très
courts en fait de sorte de deux courts
métrages qu'ils sont c'est un festival
international et encore la fin du
festival les spectateurs par vote pour
les films qu'ils ont préféré sont
rediffusés il s'implique les spectateurs
qui viennent participer à ce festival
vous le disiez refont de cette politique
culturelle on parlait du cinéma mais
plus globalement quel est la réflexion
vous avez engagé pour la rentrée on le
sait dans de nombreuses communes il faut
faire des économies et quelquefois on
sacrifie la culture est ce que c'est le
cas à bois d'arcy
alors vous allez réfléchir autour de
tout ça absolument mais malheureusement
face à la baisse des dotations de l'état
face aux contraintes budgétaires qu'on a
de plus en plus importantes on est
obligé de faire avec les moyens qu'on a
alors sur bois d'arcy la programmation
culturelle n'aura pas baissé
donc on maintient le budget la
programmation culturelle et donc la
saison culturelle qui va être lancée
donc le 18 septembre et avec le premier
spectacle 3 octobre avec la folie en
fait on a mis on a accentué la les
spectacles grand public avec une volonté
de vraiment d'être accessible à tous
quand je dis et je le répète mais c'est
important parce qu'avant c'était très
élitiste donc faire vraiment une saison
je suis élu un changement d'équipé
municipale et de bord politique pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent le désavouer
pas mal aux femmes les positions du
monde
deux visions politiques c'est clairement
un problème si j'avais une vision paul
une vision de la politique culturelle
donc là on veut vraiment faire quelque
chose d'ouvert à tous et donc lier
quatre têtes d'affiché cette saison
culturelle est une
donc on fait avec les moyens et on fait
en fait on a la chance d'avoir un
directeur de la culture geek nouveau qui
est assez imaginatifs et on arrive avec
des budgets contraints à faire des beaux
spectacles les tête d'affiche liane foly
en alu cock robin on a aussi mart michel
boujenah pardon et on anémone dans une
pièce de 80 têtes d'affiché sont
présents sur bois d'arcy pour toute
cette saison on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler bien évidemment dès la rentrée
sur notre antenne merci merci' c'est sur
ce plateau pour les amateurs de cinéma
on l'a mentionné tout à l'heure mais
sachez que le département des yvelines a
donc reconduit les yvelines font leur
cinéma il y aura une vingtaine de
communes partenaires du 20 au 30 août
avec des projections en plein air et
notamment à bois d'arcy avec le 29 août
à un dessin animé ces hôtels
transylvanie et puis à versailles est
aussi toujours pour les yvelines font
leur cinéma dans un cadre assez
exceptionnel dans le jardin de
l'établissement du trianon palace jeudi
20 août 21h le film marie antoinette
forcément de sofia coppola
merci encore c'est la fin de cette
édition du 9 juillet rendez vous de
demain vendredi pour la dernière de la
saison tout de suite filets qu avec
floriane parfait bonne soirée
[Musique]